no matter how much we may love Wildlife
the natural world is undeniably violent
the sharp teeth and Claws of carnivores
are made to tear through flesh venomous
fangs unleash deadly paralyzing toxins
but when we think of dangerous
projectiles we probably think of human
conflict humans are the only animals in
the world with the ability to throw an
object and kill a Target projectile use
by organisms other than humans is rare
however it is not unheard of because the
battle for survival is indeed a battle
nature is endlessly inventive and some
species have evolved their own version
of ballistics some beetles can let out a
barrage of toxic chemicals certain fish
can shoot prey out of the air with a
hundred percent accuracy and even
mushrooms can send their spores flying
at speeds unrivaled in the natural world
there are in fact hundreds of creatures
who have projectiles in their Arsenal
whether it's for hunting self-defense or
even procreation and these organisms
have been sources of Wonder Fascination
and confusion for centuries
Earth is home to more than 400 000
species of beetle and they can be eaten
by just about everything
frogs toads shrews birds and even other
insects like ants having so many
predators means beetles have evolved
some incredible defense mechanisms
Charles Darwin experienced this first
hand in 1846 when he was hunting on the
forest floor for different Beetle
species
having found two beetles already he
happened to see a third crawling under a
piece of bark but his hands were already
full
he said I could not bear to give up
either of my carrabbit beetles and to
lose panagius was out of the question so
that in despair I gently seized one of
the carabids between my teeth went to my
unspeakable disgust and pain the little
inconsiderate Beast squirted his acid
down my throat
chemical defenses like the one Darwin
experienced firsthand are key to more
than 500 species collectively known as
Bombardier beetles
these beetles rely on benzoquinones
toxic chemicals that are also used by
millipedes daddy long legs and many
other insects
but Bombardier beetles do something
completely unique they trigger a
chemical reaction within their bodies
that super heats the fluid and causes it
to explode out
some species are even able to aim their
spray nozzle in nearly every direction
including over their own backs
they manage this Sensational act thanks
to their unique physiology The Beatles
have two internal Chambers with volatile
chemicals in them surrounded by a
flexible membrane connected by a valve
one of the chambers contains hydrogen
peroxide and hydroquinone while the
other contains peroxidases and other
enzymes when the beetle feels threatened
it initiates the mixture of those
liquids triggering an intense exothermic
chemical reaction
the boiling hot spray is ejected in
Rapid pulses up to 20 times before the
chemicals are completely depleted
and all this happens without the beetle
sustaining any damage from the toxic
chemicals or the explosive reaction
and the chemical eruptions are extremely
good at protecting The Beetles from
predators
a group of researchers looked at how one
species of bombardier beetle fared
against toads
they allowed The Beetles to be swallowed
then could hear an explosion from inside
the stomachs of the Toads one species of
toad vomited up to 34 percent of The
Beetles and another species of vomited
back up 57 percent
whether the Beetles were in the Toad's
stomachs for only 12 minutes or up to
107 minutes they all survived the
experience and stayed alive for at least
two weeks after that
it's rare that any insect can survive
being in stomach acid for very long but
these beetles Managed IT by being
covered in mucus
another group looked at how Bombardier
beetles fared against Japanese quail as
it turned out most of the quail rejected
consuming The Beatles in the first place
even if they weren't sprayed
however other birds like Jays do ingest
the Bombardier beetles but only after
causing them to eject their spray into
the ground or into the bird's plumage
Jays seem to be too smart to get sprayed
directly but given how many Beetle
species have evolved to be bombardiers
it's clear that they're getting some
serious benefits from these explosive
abilities but in the animal kingdom not
all projectiles are chemical and not all
shoots so indiscriminately some animals
are in fact so accurate with their shots
they rival human Sharpshooters
using explosive energy to scare off
Predators is one thing but actually
shooting down prey might sound like
something else entirely like a skill
only humans have mastered but as it
turns out we're not the only ones to
hunt prey with projectiles in fact it's
not even something unique to mammals
all along the watery Mangrove forests of
the indo-pacific are schools of
archerfish who have abilities that would
give the best human Sharpshooters a run
for their money with an average size of
12 to 18 centimeters and up to 40
centimeters in the very largest species
these archerfish combine good eyesight a
unique mouth shape and incredible brains
to shoot Jets of water at prey as far as
three meters above them in lab settings
they can achieve a 100 accuracy in
hitting their targets they're so good at
manipulating water as a weapon that
they're actually considered to be tool
users
the mechanics of their water darts are
relatively straightforward archerfish
have special grooves in their mouth and
tongue that help Focus the water they
contract their Gill covers to force
water through that channel and the Jet
can be 10 times their body length
because the force is greater at the rear
the front of the water stream becomes a
blob that forcefully dislodges prey from
spiders to small lizards as the prey
Falls towards the water the archerfish
are able to make a rapid calculation of
where their prey will be and then shoot
forward using a technique called a sea
start
their bodies curve inward and
straightening propels them forward
these physical abilities are impressive
enough but for scientists the most
incredible part of the archerfish is
their brains first consider all the
challenges they face in simply locating
prey above water
in Mangrove forests where most of these
fish live the water might be murky or
have ripples on its surface from the
wind
tree roots branches and leaves might
obscure their view of the prey even when
it clings to the underside of leaves but
sometimes they'll shoot at prey on top
of the leaves based solely on its
silhouette
and all of that is before calculating
where the prey actually is
light experiences refraction as it
passes from air to water meaning the
archerfish can't aim straight at the
prey as they perceive it they have to
calibrate their shot with this
refraction in mind and they do a lot of
shooting they explore anything novel as
potential food as one group of field
researchers wrote The Fish readily shot
at cameras spherical pieces of bread
parts of equipment objects printed on
paper or the noses and eyes of
experimenters
but the fish quickly learned to identify
prey based on the reward they get from
insects falling into the water to be
gobbled up but how exactly do these fish
tell the difference between a fluttering
leaf and an insect stretching its wings
scientists aren't entirely sure but in
laboratory experiments comparing the
visual abilities of archerfish against
humans the two species performed equally
well
somehow these fish are able to
distinguish many different targets from
their background and shoot to bring them
down
and their brainy abilities don't stop
there the fish can distinguish between
smaller and larger numbers even when
that difference is relatively small like
three versus four researchers also set
up a test in which the fish were trained
to respond to images of specific human
faces and then tested by shooting water
at the required face
the researchers found the fish had an
accuracy of up to 89 percent even though
they don't have the brain structure we
normally associate with that ability
they even rely on social learning to
hone their shooting skills becoming
better at aiming over time and with more
experience in fact they're so good at
social learning that in Labs the fish
are able to become very good at a new
task just by watching another fish
perform it without doing any practicing
of Their Own
but despite their incredible Sharp
Shooting Archer fish still mostly eat
aquatic prey though they sometimes use
their water jets to dislodge Crustaceans
or small fish buried in the underwater
sediment
depending on their location aerial prey
might make up to 25 percent of their
diet
given this relatively small percentage
why did they evolve the ability to hunt
with water in the first place
scientists still aren't sure but
hypothesize that it has to do with the
fluctuating conditions of Mangrove
forests
it's also possible that Ariel prey
provides nutritional components that
they don't get from their aquatic diet
it's an ongoing question but archerfish
do prove that social skills tool use
pattern recognition and Counting don't
belong to primates alone but in fact
projectile use doesn't even belong
solely to the world of animals organisms
that can't even move themselves are
capable of some of the fastest
projectiles that Evolution has ever
crafted
we've already seen that organisms as
different as insects and fish have found
ways to incorporate ballistics into
their survival strategies but perhaps
one of the most surprising examples of
natural explosions are in fungi
they themselves may not be mobile like
other life forms but they still manage
to generate some of the fastest motions
in the natural world also that their
spores can spread as far as possible
two Genera of fungus in particular have
mastered the art of high-speed motion
despite holding perfectly still and
those are the spherobolus and pylobolus
fungi more commonly known as artillery
fungus and dung Cannon fungus
both types of fungus grow on a variety
of surfaces from wood chips to Leaf
litter to animal dung and both have
relatively small fruiting bodies that
grow towards light
the main difference comes in their two
strategies for ejecting spores as far as
possible
for both types of fungi distance is
crucial because they can't move on their
own they need a way of getting their
spores beyond the surfaces that they've
already colonized this is especially
important for the pylobolus fungi which
needs to get past the zone of repugnance
the dung it often colonizes that's
because part of its life cycle occurs in
the guts of animals so it needs to
spread its spores across grasses that an
herbivore will munch on
in order to move as far as possible
Pilobolus relies on fluid pressure
as the stock carrying the spores grows
fluid begins to swell below the Spore
the pressure builds forming a bubble
behind the Spore until it finally bursts
ejecting the Spore at incredibly high
speeds up to 210 meters per second which
is nearly as fast as a bullet
the Sphero Bullis fungi use a different
strategy to scatter its tiny spores in
the spring and Autumn when temperatures
are less than 25 degrees Celsius tiny
buds start pushing up towards the light
the spherical fruiting body is Tiny with
a diameter of just two millimeters but
at the center it holds as many as 10
million spores
all around the spores are layers woven
like a jacket which slowly peel open as
the Spore gets ready to burst free
but instead of erupting like Pilobolus
the artillery fungus spores are ejected
by a cup that suddenly pops upward like
a tiny trampoline
and what triggers this eversion is
osmotic pressure created by the
conversion of glycogen to sugars
the spores can travel up to six meters
in distance and emit a tiny popping
sound when they explode out
while the serebolis has an impressive
Spore flinging capacity it's become
something of a nuisance for homeowners
the brown and black spores stick to
vinyl siding windows and cars and can be
challenging to remove but ultimately the
fungi are harmless and an incredible
example of Nature's ingenuity
it's easy to assume that humans hold a
monopoly on inventiveness especially
when it comes to things like weapons but
as should be clear the natural world
finds plenty of ways to upend our
expectations our cleverness has helped
us develop plenty of strategies for
manipulating our environment but
sometimes Evolution can help organisms
pull off some of the same tricks to
truly understand just how incredible
some of these Feats of ballistics are in
the animal kingdom I took a quick course
on brilliant.org to wrap my head around
the mathematics behind accurate target
shooting
when researching this video my mind was
so blown by the archerfish's 100
accuracy that I wanted to know more
about how this could be possible the
classical mechanics course on brilliant
has a section about projectile motion so
I dug right in the course was
challenging but brilliant doesn't
penalize you or impede your progress
instead they give you an in-depth
explanation to guide you to the right
answer so you can learn from your
mistakes
it's easy to learn in this low pressure
environment and most importantly it's
easy to learn by doing after I finished
the course I was even more impressed by
The archerfish Who does what they do
without the help of the internet or
courses like the ones on brilliant
my favorite part of brilliant is the
interactivity seemingly daunting courses
like computer science are broken down
into fun and engaging lessons with
animations and interactive challenges
making it all so much more
understandable it's so hard to absorb
information from textbooks and college
lectures sometimes with brilliant it's
fun and almost feels like a game and
their courses are for everyone whether
you're looking to brush up or to dive
deep into math science or computer
science to get started for free visit
brilliant.org real science or click on
the link in the description and the
first 200 people will get 20 off
Brilliance annual premium subscription
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about the insane biology
of humans or watch real engineering's
latest video about the incredible
engineering of the f-35b